the AP is running a story right now
about how the younger generation up
republicans are down with the gays and
they are down
with we need and they give us a couple
examples a college republican group
leader in Alabama with nearly kicked at
the party for supporting gay marriage so
that means the leader was down with gay
marriage that something
at the successful push to legalize gay
marriage in Minnesota was backed by
several prominent younger republicans
in colorado the spokesman for a group
that push to legalize marijuana
was a republican activist he is just a
couple at the total things but there is
definitely a sense
that on the social issues mainly gay
marriage and
marijuana that the republicans are
slowly coming along
this is good news am i right humidor
well this is the way it's always been
right the republicans the conservatives
are always late to the party so I
understand how we still give any other
ideas any credence
ever so they've been bitching about gays
for ever
and whatnot they're gonna stop slowly
and soul but their next thing and then a
marijuana so they're gonna stop bitching
about marijuana and then they're gonna
finally come around to climate change
when they're all under water and the
gonna come around to
you know so it's just like what else are
you got a course you guys are wrong you
been wrong about everything what haven't
you been wrong about
you're wrong about civil rights do i
mean you're wrong about the EPA
you're wrong about fucking every hour
energy policy
you're wrong about suppressing the vote
what aren't the wrong about so what
you're young person what is it that
attractive about the Republican Party in
those stories what's great is your right
about everything whether this is not one
thing
that they're right about that one
another or yet they still continue
to manage to convince young people that
they're better on the
economy that generic term for the
economy when we know full well that that
is not the only actress is not true it
your I'll so I don't you know it's it's
frustrating and what it all
a lot of what it gets 22 is what they'll
never come around on as you know
suppressing the vote the and separate
packages they still like goodgreat other
more open a black
me the mall immigration right border but
it did at the people look different
they're still there still not on board
with that but they're good that's gonna
go away to after that lose again in 2016
they will then become the party that's
gonna try and embrace hispanics and an
immigrant they're gonna become the party
that night there that matter at the end
of the day if they do it
for principle or for doubted not tired
out as a matter of great things better
down the road yet
here's why don't think they'll do it
because as long as with what they if you
think that I'm being too harsh about
race and there are plenty of young
republicans
are racist some of them don't know yet
like with their in bed with
right real on but where they'll never
come around where the part where there
are always going to get resistance at
the top of the party
is on well they don't like poor people
and they never will
and so when you when there's this
thought that republicans after 2016 will
cover out on immigration reform
was people earning those people are
still poor and may install the
government assistance you know what
any party that that is going to be a
very tough reconcile for the I think
and in that story by the way you see
that like
that that that in that list that you
gave that young republic at Alabama
min she was still nearly together party
that was a woman
but but the head of the republican party
in Alabama was still like you know
that was very bad yep you know he was
like that we didn't like that that was
incongruous it didn't work so
I mean like those are anecdotal stories
and I mean they're proven
its incremental they've moved the ball
from the half yard line
to the three quarters of the 1-yard line
to me they had 99 yards in 11
love them really helps move them yeah
doesn't I think we can live jeb bush I
think object bush's the nominee that
there they
he's gonna change the party about
immigration per share forever both my
love immigrants they are at you in your
room his brother was a
compassionate conservative he added me
take up until he loves immigrants yes so
they said okay but now
well yes of course you know and he has
the he has the
the Colombian part of his fam will
happen families married to call me
they said the people who come here he
said that they're doing at the moral
actor trying to help their family
they're being moral that's what you're
supposed to do they want to come here
and working up their family
and we should try to help them instead
of trying to shoot out now so you're
saying that the cold calculated
political movie not something he
necessarily
I think its bowl but it's going to
require money it's gonna require these
people are poor
many of them are dirt-poor and I think
that's going to be a very tough sell
a very tough sell for republicans who
that is that is
at that a call to who they are helping
other people yes really help they don't
wanna with people who donated
picked up right where wait to get back
to to weeding gay marriage or so
do you guys think this is just gonna be
a state by state thing for both of them
or is there any point the federal
government got a job in
what could there especially gay marriage
I mean it's just every week it's another
one we've seen it yet luck there they
the
a venture that look realism will take
over and they're important issues are
making sure
that the people who are gonna vote for
Democrats can't vote for Democrat yes
that's job one for them game your like
the pope
like there's a degree oven you see some
Republican attorneys general around the
country
realizing I'm not gonna fight anymore
this is a silly thing
this is a silly effort to be fighting on
on gay marriage like we're gonna lose
edits done and sadly as the pope said
hey look I i'm against abortion and I'm
anti
a gay marriage but I'm in that it
shouldn't talk yet and what the hell
back she said was if someone wants to
invite me to a disco party slam home I
to condemn but
redacted redacted up should the Tea
Party in the libertarians
so the Ronde the Rand Paul's shouldn't
they be four
legalization of weed and for gay
marriage they were they were
Ron Paul what they are Barack right by
Rampaul is not for
gay marriage as far as I know it really
sorta been weird about we do
but he wants you to have individual
liberty and individual rights in this
wheelhouse stuff if they were being
intellectually honest well
yet he talked up 0.8 Rampal I
Rand Paul is trying to play a delicate
game where he can be you right wing
enough to get the nomination
and the ill for him it'll be that a
fairly easy track to the center yet we
know
like ices we presume about Rand Paul
is care about gay marriage a doesn't
care about weed those are
that important or right being a republic
what he doesn't want to deal with fall
into the trap
old being his father who appeals to
a bunch of kids in college but when it
really gets serious that he's
marginalized in seen he
he needs to be seen as look at me I'm
one of those tablets mint
but I'm still have this little cocoon
rock-hard out at the bear
it would be very hard for him so we're
agreed though in theory that I read a
bleed on
that's gonna held at a rare it
ultimately get a place like that all you
remember he's also a club
the CAF president yeah exactly 0 but in
theory they should be four gay marriage
and legalization of weed Ray Bradbury
for terry if they should be but is there
a libertarian that is should although
should also be right yet but where are
those guys well I mean economic
I guess conservatives do with social
conservatives should run
i know i mean Georgia you need to
articulate what they should get there
being true to their ideas yes it did
look order established that the country
is to follow
but the Conservatives correct me if I'm
wrong you know there are strict
constructionist with the government with
the cunt constitution so they would say
less government
and you don't be a the same the
Constitution you can regulate
my marijuana or my marriage so you can
get to do that i think thats what a real
conservative
would say the real conservative would
say I'm not for abortion but i'm for the
government's they not a bit
right or so that's the difference really
don't but I don't think I would estimate
because there's a marriage if those
strict constructionist and religious
conservatives
ratner the issue so final thought on
this which goes right to that
is abortion X for them after these two
things are starting every there any
chance that they'll see that he leaves
changing
and and that the huge numbers that some
order to stop biting it
the stops biting are the greatest ever
other huge I think it's something it's
closer to like sixty percent healthy
exchange about you know bob or she will
always stay the same right that I'll
always be an issue for them because
decides not to move forward is that it's
always the same thing either you think
it's a baby or you don't and so they can
always
tug at your heart strings and get you to
feel that way so that's why this
won't change I i think but everything
else is changing their abortion is a
much more intellectually
to get to is a much more intellectually
honest argument yes
but being anti-abortion a few believe
that
I don't think its dangers to women did
not believe that but
it is more intellectually honest another
i think is right now I think those
numbers are basically stayed the same
and as we saw in that story go a public
int art actually moving
on abortion their actions that that
while they're still connected to the
and really do know that God is still
anti-abortion because
if you have an abortion and have another
kid he will make it downs baby
uphold
up